die tatsache dass wir zum
zweitbeliebtesten land der welt gehören
hat natürlich auch ganz viel damit zu
tun dass wir menschen freundlich sind
das wir
human sind aber dass wir auch
realistisch bleiben müssen und was ich
trotzdem vermisse ist das sozusagen auch
diese fragen zusammen mit der ganzen
gesellschaft auch beantwortet und
geklärt werden müssen dass das sozusagen
keine einzelfall entscheidungen sind
sondern dass wir eine
einwanderungspolitik machen müssen für
dieses land für deutschland nicht für
migranten nicht für flüchtlinge sondern
für uns alle
und da bin ich mir sicher dass jeder der
das auch vernünftig erklärt bekommt auch
mit geht bei denjenigen die
schutzbedürftig sind und trotzdem sage
ich dass die ängste die damit verbunden
sind und die im raum stehen dass sie
auch ernst genommen werden müssen und
die kommen ja auch von unterschiedlichen
seiten und wir können dinge wie
religiösen extremismus terrorismus den
können wir nicht verhindern genauso
wenig wie wir rassismus verhindern
können das heißt haben sich menschen auf
den weg hierher gemacht und waren
darunter auch menschen die getötet haben
ja aber waren darunter auch menschen die
getötet wurden aus rassistischen motiven
auch jahr und das zeigt eben es gibt
kein schwarz oder weiß und wenn jemand
vor allem assad-regime fried dann ist er
auf der einen seite opfer er kann aber
trotzdem auch täter gewesen sein weil
der islamist war das heißt diese
gemengelage mehr berücksichtigen da sind
unsere sicherheitsbehörden gefragt da
ist sozusagen auch im zusammenwirken
aller europäischen länder gefragt und da
ist vor allem auch eine europäische
antwort gefragt auch hier gilt wieder
die zivilgesellschaft ist schon viel
weiter als die institutionen und europa
muss hier antworten liefern
deswegen christine dürfte das ich möchte
auch als eine politik fordern ich möchte
dass wegen der arzt präsidentschaft in
der warum hat ruft frau merkel jetzt
nicht ein sondergipfel zusammen um
konkret jetzt für ihren nicht die große
frage wie gehen wir in zukunft was in
die strategien konkret hilfe von ria
warum passiert das nicht das wäre meine
forderung
[Musik]